[Music]
there's a huge opportunity an unmet need
of our technology being more
understanding of us and us being more
understanding of what the capabilities
of the technology are so we can have
this rich meaningful experience
collaborating with the technologies and
working with the technologies so in that
sense making our technology more
emotionally aware it is a key part in
making that experience meaningful you're
listening to the Microsoft Research
podcast a show that brings you closer to
the cutting edge of technology research
and the scientists behind it
I'm your host Gretchen heusinger using
technology to help us improve our health
is nothing new a quick web search
returns hundreds of apps and devices
claiming to help us get fit quit smoking
master anxiety or just find our Center
what is new is a serious cohort of
researchers exploring how artificial
emotional intelligence or AEI
could help us understand ourselves
better and when used in concert with
human caregivers enhance our well-being
one of those researchers is Gena Suh a
former Xbox developer who got hooked on
research and is now in our SDE and the
human understanding and empathy group at
MSR as well as a PhD student in computer
science at the University of Washington
on today's podcast Gena shares her
passion for creating technologies that
promote emotional resilience in mental
health gives us an inside look at an
innovative research collaboration that
aims to improve collaborative care for
cancer patients with depression and
tells us an emotional story of how on
the brink of quitting her job she found
inspiration to get back in the game and
begin a new career and research for
human wellbeing that and much more on
this episode of the Microsoft Research
podcast
[Music]
Gina sue welcome to the podcast
thank you you work in an interesting
space Gina your title is research
software design engineer you're
currently working in a group called Hugh
or the human understanding and empathy
group at MSR and you're beginning your
doctoral studies in computer science at
the University of Washington in broad
strokes
tell us what motivates you to do the
work you do and what gets you up in the
morning what gets me up in the morning
is actually an alarm clock no but really
it's my daughter she's really my
inspiration I get up to do what I set
out to do because I want to make the
world a better place for her I want to
show that you know being a working mom
is hard but it's really rewarding and
that learning never stops so I want to
show her that you can redefine yourself
at any age under any circumstances so I
do work in technology for human
understanding and well-being so I think
in terms of mental health and human
well-being I think all of us at some
point go through experiences where we
feel like we're not in control of our
emotions or our lives we go through very
stressful moments we go through very sad
moments I think there's a huge
opportunity for us to develop
technologies that helps us understand
you know who we are one of the feelings
that we're having and really help us
reflect and be the better version of
ourselves where is it that we would need
technology to help us be better versions
of ourselves or to overcome obstacles in
our emotional and mental health think in
a lot of ways we have the capability to
kind of look at what we've done and
reflect on our past and figure out why
we're feeling certain ways but that
takes effort and motivation and training
and practice too so a lot of people need
professional help through you know
therapies - yeah
develop the skills in order to reflect
but I think technology especially with
multimodal sensing technologies we have
the opportunity to bring the information
to the person and help them look at
their behaviors in ways that human
memories cannot fathom right in some
ways what I'm hearing you say is that if
we can set a timer or an alarm for some
physical thing we have to do why
couldn't we have technology prompt us on
things that we have to do for our mental
health right I know a lot of our mental
health influences our productivity and
our work I'm not I'm thinking and our
decision-making so I think it's
absolutely necessary for us to schedule
for ourselves to reflect and also
practice mmm the skills that we need to
do to reflect and be mindful just like
we practice for work and for exercises
well we'll get to the specifics on that
in a second
but let's go back upstream a little bit
you have a dev but you say now you only
code when you need to when do you need
to oh and I have an idea okay cool I was
wondering about that you've also done
some work in machine learning in HCI and
you say you're a proud alumnus of
patrisa marts
machine teaching group tell us a little
bit about your previous work and how
it's informed the work that you do now
so I started as a developer in Xbox I
worked in Xbox for seven plus years and
I always admired the design team and
loved working with them and you know
trying to understand the rationale
behind their design choices and I wanted
to do more high-level thinking you know
be closer to our customers and you know
build things that are more meaningful
and have genuine reasons why we're
building them so I stumbled across
something called HCI or human-computer
interaction or HCD human centered design
and at the same time I stumbled across
this machine teaching group which
claimed to be this focus on like
studying the people interacting with
machines and you know when I started
working in the group I
also started my part-time master's
program at University of Washington in
human centered design and engineering so
at first I was just helping the group
build their machine teaching tool and
then I got to help build prototypes or
user studies and then help run the
studies and eventually design studies
using the knowledge that I was gaining
from my masters and also through work
and I just fell in love with the science
of it all and really observing people
using the tools in the way that you
hypothesize so slowly and maturely I
started doing more independent research
forming my own projects and contributing
to research and I'm pretty much hooked
now I am a firm believer of the machine
teaching principles you know this idea
of empowering the human teacher and I
believe I can take those learnings and
apply in other domains right and some
exciting ones too mm-hmm I want to talk
a bit more in depth about this human
understanding and empathy or hue group
tell us in more detail what's going on
in hue and who's doing what right now
the mission of the hue team is to really
empower people by creating and inventing
new technologies that promote emotional
resilience and well-being it's really
grounded in the fact that emotions are
fundamental to human interactions and
they influence everything that we do is
starting from learning memory
decision-making and all these other
aspects of our lives
so you know how do we bring emotional
intelligence to technology is kind of
the core of our research tell me a
little bit more about this idea of
emotional intelligence and emotional
resilience because this isn't something
we normally associate with computer
science especially in the research areas
so as humans we actually generate a lot
of data about how we're feeling or what
we're thinking we have body language we
have the way that we speak kind of the
faces that we make it's really difficult
to process all of that data all at once
so we need the help from computers and
technology to not only capture all of
that information but also help us make
sense of it data
by analyzing the information computers
have been ubiquitous in our lives and we
expect more meaningful interactions with
our technologies and we want our
technologies to understand this in some
sense and I think there's a huge
opportunity an unmet need of our
technology being more understanding of
us and us being more understanding of
what the capabilities of the technology
are so we can have this rich meaningful
experience collaborating with the
technologies and working with the
technologies so in that sense making our
technology more emotionally aware is a
key part in making that experience
meaningful so there's a lot to unpack
there in terms of how you translate
human emotions into machine language and
we'll get there in a second but I want
to go back to this idea of human
centered design to me that implies
there's been a significant amount of
design that wasn't human centered what
can we do to change that
so I think we missed the mark in two
ways one is that we often simplify
humans because it makes the problem more
elegant and easy to solve and we see
this happening in machine learning
research you know humans are mindless
label generating Oracle's you know if
you collect enough labels on whether a
person on this photo is happy or not we
can build emotionally intelligent models
but the truth is humans are a lot more
complex than that and we tend to ignore
the things that are really difficult so
you know I talk to a lot of data
scientists about bias and machine
learning you know everybody knows that
bias is a real problem but because it's
hard to tackle it's not their area of
expertise you know it's ignore it or
deep prioritize so that's one thing yeah
another thing is that you know we give
ourselves too much credit you know we
assume that we know the problem and jump
to solutions too quickly we say to
ourselves that users don't know what
they need if you ask them you know I
don't know if you know the famous quote
by Henry Ford if you ask people what
they needed
they'd say faster horse so I think if
you do your user research right you'll
not
we find the right problem so it also
through this iterative design process
you discover the right solution that is
the automobile you know not only that
you will also be able to contextualize
your solution in more detail in
real-life situations and you know the
best part of my job is actually talking
to users about their problems and
hearing their frustrations and
complaints and really the hardest part
is not jumping to the solutions and it
takes effort and discipline to stay true
to your users problems and we often
ignore this that so you talk to the
users when we talked about human health
and well-being we talked about some of
the problems human practitioners face
and you mentioned two specific ways that
technology might help us attack these
problems and they were sensing an
intervention could you unpack these
concepts for us and tell us how they
might play out in the human and
technical worlds how might technology
augment and fill in human gaps here I
want to use productivity as an example
since we are a Productivity company
right so you know people go through a
wide range of emotions throughout their
workday and we have certain events or
experiences maybe a bad meeting which
could trigger negative emotion states
like anxiety and stress and that leads
to unhealthy behaviors more loss of
productivity or even poor
decision-making so you know first step
of coping with negative emotional states
like stress would be awareness which not
only involves understanding the triggers
that led to the stress but reflecting
how your stress is presented in your
behavior so that's when censing comes in
because it's difficult for people to
associate these triggers with their
behaviors and the emotions so multimodal
sensing assists people with the
collection of contextual data and it
might actually help you learn salient
features and patterns that actually
correlate the stress and negative
emotional states to your behaviors right
so that's the multimodal sensing part
and then there's the intervention part
where
we want to help people make sense of
their behaviors and actually do
something about it
perhaps interact with the sensing
technology to tweak it personalize it
you know which is an important machine
teaching moment and work with this
emotionally intelligent agent to may be
surface interventions at the right
moments you know so you can imagine
having a just-in-time cognitive
reframing for some people this could be
after the fact reflection for some other
people studies have shown that the best
time to practice some of these
interventions is when the person is at
his or her best self so providing the
right intervention at the right time is
key for sustaining engagement and mental
health care so let me enter interrupt
here what might that look like a
just-in-time intervention if I'm
stressed and my device whatever it is
that senses it alerts me and proposes
that I reflect and so on do I have to
wait till I'm at my better self it can
intervene on myself as it were I think
that's where the personalization comes
in everybody's different so imagine you
you have anger management problems I
don't have to imagine and some some
intelligent thing tells you hey you're
about to have an angry bout you would be
even more angry or some people want to
get interventions
some people want others to tell them
what to do we have done studies in the
past where we've analyzed different
types of people what kinds of control
they want to have so people were more
you know quote unquote control freaks
yeah are less likely to want to engage
in these just-in-time behaviors and
people who are less control freaks are
more likely so we really need to
personalize and really understand the
person right and be able to give the
control to the person to adjust and
tweak these
I want to talk about the collaboration
between the University of Washington and
Microsoft Research I know you've got a
foot in both places so we just talked
about bridging gaps between humans and
machines and how one can complement the
other but there's also gaps that exist
between people talk about why it's
important to have both medical and
technical experts working together in
this hybrid space we try to make
meaningful contributions to the space of
human well-being and hopefully make
notable differences in mental health we
really need expertise in clinical
psychology but because we don't have the
expertise in clinical psychology
in-house we have to work with people
from outside of our company so our
pocket skills which is a mobile app that
we developed that mary cywinski our
manager spearheaded and we collaborated
with marcia lennon who is the creator
and expert in dialectical behavior
therapy
DBT and Chelsea Wilkes who is a clinical
psychologist we collaborated with them
to translate this proven in session
therapy technique to a digital format in
a mobile app and currently I'm working
with University of Washington psychiatry
and behavioral sciences faculties to
develop technologies that we're actually
going to build and test its clinical
efficacy so again without the experts in
these fields we are not able to truly
validate the efficacies of these
technologies I think there is a
significant community within the medical
field
where they develop these apps and they
actually do test for clinical efficacy
but on the technology side I think we
have an opportunity to inform the design
and the implementation of some of the
technologies in the medical field and we
also have an opportunity
to gain the knowledge and expertise that
medical specialists have and bring it to
the technologists so that we actually do
build things that are useful let's talk
about a specific project you're working
on called are you ready designing
technology enhanced collaborative care
for cancer patients with depression
usually long titles like that have some
clever acronym but no this one doesn't
even make a word I don't know do you
have a nickname for it it's really hard
someone's got to figure our name out
that rolls off the tongue in any case I
want you to talk about this research in
detail because our listeners may not
even know much about the topic let alone
the technical approach to helping with
the intervention so what are some of the
underlying problems in what you call
collaborative care and why do you think
technology could help so I think I need
to explain why collaborative care is
first so a collaborative care model is
one implementation model where basically
behavioral health care or mental health
care is tightly integrated into whatever
medical care settings so it could be
primary care and in my case it's cancer
care the idea is that you know cancer
patients do develop mental health
disorders because they're going through
a tremendous stress if the medical team
discovers that you need this additional
mental health support because you have
depression anxiety and other things they
engage what they call care coordinators
or care managers to help you treat your
psychosocial needs and you have
psychiatrists if you need additional you
know medication support or if you
develop a mental health disorder that's
complex you involve psychiatrists who
can not only consult on the cases but
also provide kind of medication
prescription support so it's this idea
of putting the patient at the center and
having the oncologists or providers or
physicians work with your care providers
who deliver the day-to-day behavioral
health care and the psychotic
who's giving guidance on medication and
prescriptions so that's collaborative
care in a nutshell yeah and these care
managers are often social workers and
not only are they supposed to give you
this behavioral health care whether it's
you know be a behavioral activation or
CBT cognitive behavioral therapy or
whatever these interventions and
treatments not only are their tasks to
do that
they're also tasks to do these
navigational support things you know
financial aid making sure you have
housing making sure you're taking your
medication and making sure you can get
to the Cancer Center and get the care
and get the infusion and treatment and
whatnot so they're overwhelmed they're
truly overwhelmed so what are some ways
that we can reduce the workload of these
social workers so one of the things that
we notice is that these social workers
are having to do a lot of things during
their sessions with their patients
including things like administrating
validated mental health scales so phq-9
which measures depression and got7 which
measures anxiety and that takes away 10
minutes out of a 30-minute session so
one-third of your session is spent on
administrating this thing so you know
you could do it all side of the session
you could do it at the waiting room
that's great but in reality these
patients come in and out of the clinics
almost daily because they're getting
infusions so they're really burnt out
and they don't want to see another
person they just want to go home so you
know adding this additional burden like
you have to stay in the waiting room for
this much longer to fill out this form
or sometimes they cancel appointments
and reschedule appointments because
they're just burnt out what are ways to
help these patients engage in mental
health care on their own you know
sometimes without having to come to the
clinic and then also help social workers
be less burdened with the workload that
they have so one of the things that we
could do is you know offline remote
assessment so have technology that pings
the patients once in a while and
measures their depression
anxiety and when that skill goes up you
know if you measure high depression all
of a sudden bring them in for care is
that self reporting then mm-hmm okay
yeah most of these scales are done as a
self reporting tool anyways they get
handed a piece of paper anybody
sometimes it's in a supervised setting
and my question would be if I'm
depressed and I'm alone am I just gonna
hit the snooze button right and that
already happens even without technology
right a lot of the patients don't want
to come into the clinic especially when
they're depressed they don't want to
engage so that's already a challenge but
most of the times these patients are
sitting in their bed using their phones
or watching TV using these opportunities
to bring up you know hey it's really
important to know where you are in terms
of your depression and anxiety scale
like do you want to self-assess right
now or hey it looks like you've been
sitting at your bed for a long time you
need to go out and take a log let's go
do that one of the things that we
discovered that patients are missing in
this traditional mental healthcare sense
is that because social work in cancer
settings it's not billable which means
that there is no formal scheduling for
them which means they don't get to go
through the standard process that other
providers do basically they don't get
treated as an official provider which
means there's no after-visit summary
that you get when you go see your
primary physician right you get this
like little printed out paper that says
you're supposed to do this go take these
medications these social workers don't
get to do that because they don't even
have a scheduler so a lot of times what
you end up discussing during the
sessions are forgotten or it's written
on up sticky note and lost but we also
know that people carry around their cell
phones all the time so if they could
have the after visit summaries and notes
and their action items things that they
are supposed to do if we can have
technology that not just them in the
right way to actually take those actions
and also
help them remember what they're supposed
to do because it's written down and it's
recorded in your app that's a huge area
of opportunity that is not there
currently
[Music]
we're at the point in the podcast where
I ask what could possibly go wrong
I'm imagining as we talk that I'm a
cancer patient and depressed and anyone
who's ever struggled with depression for
any reason knows how difficult it is to
do anything even if you're reminded you
know at what point if I have my phone
telling me something is there a handoff
where there's a human because I might
just ignore my machine but somebody who
hugs me or somebody who's talking to me
face to face and says Gretchen I'm here
for you we can do this together
is there a bridge to the human through
what you're talking about in your
interventions right what we're trying to
do is not replace humans in any way but
augment the human capabilities I think
the social workers are already
overloaded so if we can reduce their
workload by making their work a lot more
efficient now they have the opportunity
to give a call to their patients and say
hey how are you doing one of the things
that we discover this a lot of the
patients go through these crisis moments
and they want to talk to somebody
they're not suicidal so they don't see
the need to call the suicide hotline but
they're just going through a hard time
and we ask them you know how can we help
support that and most of the time people
said I just want to text with my social
worker I just want to text with somebody
that I know mm-hmm who understands my
situation so we're trying to brainstorm
ideas around how do we make that
possible and also understand that social
workers are burden then they have a life
to live when the Apple you know crises
don't happen between the 9:00 to 5:00
right in the business hours so how do we
make that possible by balancing the
needs of both individuals it's a really
tough problem but I think there's a way
you know obviously reducing the workload
of the social workers and having them
have more time to engage is one thing
and giving the patients opportunity and
maybe a social group and support network
to talk about their issues would be
another way mm-hmm well let's go in a
little further on the what keeps you up
at night even as we've talked you've
triggered some thoughts in my mind
number one is the privacy issues that
are involved especially when they deal
with my mental health so that's one area
I'd like you to talk about and the other
one is the shift towards machines and
devices to meet our needs rather than
humans I know that I've just unloaded a
bunch of thoughts unload back on me I
think again I want to stress that we're
trying to take advantage of technology
as a mediator to help connect people as
opposed to replace the human to human
connection so the metric that I would
probably optimize for is not how often
does this patient use my technology but
how often does this person engage in the
care and actually engage with the social
worker so you know what keeps me up at
night is do I have the right objectives
and am I actually meeting the goals of
that objective in terms of the privacy I
think one thing that people assume is
you have the sensing technology it's
creepy
you know it's watching me all the time
but you also have to understand we're
not forcing you to have this we want you
to use this technology for yourself for
your own good so if you're not
comfortable don't do it but if you see
the need and if you see the benefit of
this technology in helping you remember
what happened helping you reflect
helping you get out of that tough
situation then by all means why wouldn't
you use it what I'm trying to get at is
that there are some points in your
therapy session where your social worker
or your therapist will ask you know what
happened and you may realize that you
can't remember you can recall that makes
this session less efficient I think
there are ways to
negotiate this boundary that you have of
your comfort level and that negotiation
has to happen by you realizing through
the help of your social worker and
therapists where is the line that you
want to draw and what's the need that
you have to me it all goes back to
settings you know I'm gonna pick the
strength of of intervention or sensing
that I want yeah but you as a patient
and you as a user sometimes don't know
where that setting has to be and it's
really the therapist or the social
worker that helps you decide okay this
data is really important because with
this data I'm going to make this
clinical adjustment and that's a buying
process you sure the social worker has
to convince that that data is important
for clinical reasons you know that's a
super good point because there might be
people that really really need it and
say I don't need it and that's where
you're looking at them going yeah you do
let's work on getting you to the point
where you can embrace who's your
audience for this is this technology
really for this social worker and the
therapists not so much the oncologist or
the primary care physician right now
we're targeting just the social workers
and the therapists and the care managers
because they're the ones that know
everything they're the go-to person for
the patient they're the hub of all the
information okay it's story time here on
the Microsoft Research podcast we know
about the work you're doing but not much
about you as a person accept the fact
that you're like doing a lot of work and
you've had a lot of experiences already
in your fairly short life what's your
background how did young Gina sue get
involved in high-tech and how did she
end up at Microsoft Research I studied
physics as an undergrad and astronomy I
did research in astrophysics I got
involved in particle physics and I
aspired to be an experimental particle
physicist
I worked at CERN for a summer so I went
on to get my PhD in physics and felt
like I was making kind of a very ass
track contribution which
anybody's studying physics like by all
means go for it
but for me personally I felt like I
needed to do something that was directly
impactful to people so I started looking
around for jobs and there are only two
kinds of jobs that you could get as a
physics graduate which is quantitative
trading in finance or some sort of a
data science or you know computer
science and tech yeah so I got an
internship at Microsoft I fell in love
with it and I just decided I'm gonna
pursue my career in coding I don't have
a computer science background at all the
only class that I took was in intro to C
and you know there I learned how to
manipulate some memories and arrays and
things like that but I never really knew
how to code so I picked all of that up
at work
somehow I started as a nest that I
started as a tester and then I had moved
my way through becoming a developer so
all of that happened
while I was working in Xbox and this was
during the launch of Xbox one and I
don't know if you understand the
pressure that you feel when you're not
only shipping software but you're also
shipping brand-new hardware we were
working day and night or the weekends
and I had a four year old at the time
and I asked myself what am I doing here
I have a four year old at home so right
after the Xbox one release I had decided
to quit my job I wanted to become a
stay-at-home mom and dedicate myself to
my child and I had an opportunity to
give a talk on behalf of somebody at
Grace Hopper and I was like okay I'm
just gonna go do it and you know I told
myself I'm gonna quit my job after this
conference I'm gonna tell my manager at
the time the keynote speaker was Sheryl
Sandberg and I heard about meaning I
didn't read it but I figured not only is
she the keynote speakers I was also
invited to a breakfast with her so I got
to know this person so my husband put
lean in on the Kindle I started reading
it from the airport
I read it on the plane I read it at the
hotel when I got there I stayed up all
night reading the book just crying my
eyes out crying my eyes why am i
deciding to quit my job I can't do this
I can't add to that number of women who
gave up so that gave me a lot of hope to
you know pick myself back up get back on
the field and so that's when I started
looking into other job opportunities I
need to get out of what I was doing I
need to do something that's meaningful I
need to do something that has good
work-life balance but also you know it's
something I can be passionate about and
I look towards Microsoft research
because somebody else told me oh yeah
they're developer positions at Microsoft
Research really I didn't know that so I
applied I had great interviews I fell in
love with the people that I was talking
with with the project the idea of
helping people empowering people
developing these technologies studying
people I just fell in love with it all
and that's how I got started in
Microsoft research as we close I always
ask my guests to give us some parting
thoughts and I usually ask it in terms
of advice to our listeners but I want to
tweak the question and and ask it less
as advice and more as what excites you
most about where you're heading with
research what technology wave do you
want to catch and ride so right now
there are a lot of changes that are
happening in mental health you know
we're putting mental health as the
number one epidemic people are not
afraid to talk about it you know we see
the epidemic and teens are becoming more
depressed right now we're seeing changes
in policy we're seeing changes to
healthcare in terms of mental health so
I think this is the right moment to
really get into the space of mental
health and have that conversation we
need to have that conversation now so
that it's not too late ten years from
now we have this emotionally intelligent
agent you know having to figure out like
what does it mean
how does it impact our lives if we get
there at the very beginning of it I
think we will evolve with the rest of
the world we will evolve with the policy
changes that are happening and the
insurance changes that are happening the
attitude changes and stigma changes that
are happening so I want to be part of
the conversation now Gina sue thank you
so much for joining us today has been
delightful thank you for having me to
learn more about Gina sue and the latest
in technologies for human health and
well-being visit
microsoft.com/testlabguides
[Music]